rascarse guardar
[Música]
enmanuel manjón tiene grandes planes
tras acudir la política francesa en 2017
a sus 39 años el presidente más joven en
llegar al palacio del elíseo está
ansioso por aplicar reformas radicales
pero pronto tendría que dejar en
suspenso planes críticos obligado a
afrontar una crisis tras otra
en noviembre de 2018 decenas de
manifestantes con chalecos amarillos
salían a la calle enfadados por un
aumento de los impuestos sobre el
combustible y más en general por la
política fiscal del gobierno el
movimiento apunta directamente a makro
que intenta apaciguar a los
manifestantes con miles de millones de
euros en reformas sociales pero no sirve
de mucho para calmarlos
[Música]
el movimiento de los chalecos amarillos
está ya seguido de la pandemia así que
toda la sensación de esta presidencia es
casi como un parón que nunca ha
encontrado su ritmo y eso ha sido muy
difícil de gestionar creo
[Música]
manning añadiendo más leña al fuego la
indignación pública por la reforma de
las pensiones en 2019 lleva a protestas
generalizadas seguidas de una huelga de
transportes de seis semanas una de las
más largas en la historia de francia
entonces una crisis que nadie vio venir
un virus transmitido por el aire
conocido como kobe 19 comienza a
extenderse por todo el mundo el gobierno
de macrón decreta un estricto bloqueo y
recibe duras críticas por desestimar
inicialmente la importancia de las
mascarillas pero macrón es capaz de dar
la vuelta a la opinión pública con la
imposición de un pase sanitario y con
inyecciones masivas de dinero para la
economía que le valieron el apoyo de la
mayoría de los franceses mientras se
enfrentaba a los defensores anti vacunas
admitiendo que quería fastidiar los
sexo en general el proceso fue un éxito
alentando a los franceses a vacunarse
pero también la opinión política general
de que eso era algo bueno no sufrió por
eso pero fue un movimiento bastante
considerable que no funcionó en su
contra
weinstein
luego en febrero de 2022 akrón se
enfrenta a su mayor prueba en el
escenario mundial cuando rusia invadió
cráneo intenta negociar un acuerdo de
paz hablando repetidamente con vladimir
putin intentando coordinar una respuesta
europea de crisis en crisis está por ver
si el historial de macon le ayudará a
llegar al palacio del elíseo durante
otros cinco años